♪ ♪
>> WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT, WE WANT TO BRING YOU
THE LATEST ON WHAT WAS A
REMARKABLE STORY THAT BROKE LATE
REMARKABLE STORY THAT BROKE LATF
REMARKABLE STORY THAT BROKE LATI
REMARKABLE STORY THAT BROKE LATA
REMARKABLE STORY THAT BROKE LATY
REMARKABLE STORY THAT BROKE LATI
REMARKABLE STORY THAT BROKE LATN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," IN NO TIME
TO ADDRESS AT THE END.
ACCORDING TO WHAT OUR APPARENTLY
HIGH-LEVEL SOURCES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN 2017
THE FBI SECRETLY BEGAN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT IS IN FACT A RUSSIAN
AGENT, THE FBI APPARENTLY
BELIEVE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
COULD BE A ONE-MAN SLEEPER CELL.
PERSONALLY TAKING DIRECT ORDERS
FROM HIS HANDLERS IN MOSCOW, AND
WORKING FROM WITHIN THE
OVAL OFFICE TO SUBVERT THIS
COUNTRY.
THE FBI SAID THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT COULD'VE HAPPENED.
SO THEY SPIED APPARENTLY ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WHILE, SHOCKING, DOES NOT EVEN
BEGIN TO DESCRIBE THE STORY.
NOTHING LIKE THIS HAS EVER
HAPPENED IN THIS COUNTRY.
THESE ALLEGATIONS ARE LITERALLY
WITHOUT PRECEDENT, THAT IS NOT
AN OVERSTATEMENT.
AND THE ALLEGATIONS ARE NOT TRU
TRUE.
THE FBI DID NOT FIND THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS AN FBI AGENT, NO
CHARGES WERE FILED AGAINST THEM.
NONE WILL BE, BUT AN EQUALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION REMAINS
UNANSWERED.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
DECIDING THE SITTING PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED FOR
TREASON IS NOT A SMALL THING.
OFFICIALS WITHIN THE FBI HAD TO
PUSH FOR THIS INVESTIGATION.
AND THEN MARSHALL EVIDENCE TO
JUSTIFY IT.
LEGAL LEADERS HAD TO SIGN OFF ON
THE WHOLE THING, ALL OF THAT
HAPPEN.
BUT ON WHAT GROUNDS EXACTLY?
THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD NEED TO
KNOW IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND THI
THIS.
WELL, THANKS TO THE "TIMES"
STORY WE HAVE SOME SENSE OF THE
ANSWER.
IF YOU ARE IMAGINING A SECRET
TRANSMITTER DISCOVERED HIDDEN IN
THE LINCOLN BEDROOM, NO.
THINK AGAIN.
THERE WERE NO CLOAK AND DAGGER
CLUES IN THIS CASE, APPARENTLY.
THE FBI ASSUMED THAT
DONALD TRUMP MIGHT BE A RUSSIAN
AGENT NOT BECAUSE OF ANYTHING HE
DID IN SECRET, BUT BECAUSE OF
THINGS HE SAID IN PUBLIC.
VERY PUBLIC.
A STANDING ON THE STAGE ON
CAMERA WHILE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
HERE'S ONE OF THEM.
>> THERE IS NOTHING THAT I CAN
THINK OF THAT I WOULD RATHER DO
THAN HAVE RUSSIA FRIENDLY AS
OPPOSED TO THE WAY THAT THEY ARE
RIGHT NOW.
WANTED TO BE NICE IF WE ACTUALLY
GOT ALONG AS AN EXAMPLE WITH
RUSSIA?
I AM ALL FOR IT.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP SPEAKING AT A
PRESS CONFERENCE IN JULY OF
2016.
ACCORDING TO THE FBI THE WORDS
THAT YOU JUST HEARD ARE EVIDENCE
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT HAVE
BETRAYED THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS THEIR VIEW.
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER WAY TO LOOK
AT THOSE WORDS.
MAYBE TRUMP IS RIGHT.
RUSSIA IS A NUCLEAR ARMED POWER
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE PLANET,
IT DOES NOT HAVE THE POWER TO
INVADE THE UNITED STATES.
IT CANNOT CLOSE INTERNATIONAL
SHIPPING LANES, IT DOES NOT
SERIOUSLY THREATEN OUR KEY
ALLIES LIKE JAPAN OR
GREAT BRITAIN.
IS THERE SOME REASON, THEN, THAT
WE SHOULD INHERENTLY BE IN
CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA?
IS THERE MORE OVER A VAST PUBLIC
SUPPORT IN THIS COUNTRY FOR
FIGHTING A PROXY WAR IN SYRIA
WITH THE KREMLIN?
AND HOW MANY AMERICAN PARENTS
ARE ANXIOUS TO SEND THEIR KIDS
TO DIE FOR THE TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY OF UKRAINE?
AN ISSUE THAT WE ARE SUPPOSED
SOMETHING IS VERY IMPORTANT.
OUTSIDE OF A FEW NEIGHBORHOODS
IN WASHINGTON, NOT VERY MANY
PEOPLE, IT TURNS OUT.
SO TRUMP DID RAISE A FAIR
QUESTION AT THE PRESS CONFERENCE
IN 2016.
IN WASHINGTON SAYING THAT OUT
LOUD IS CONSIDERED TREASON.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN POLICIES
ALMOST BEING PARROTED BY
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU HAD TRUMP SAY ONLY NICE
THINGS ABOUT PUTIN, HE NEVER
SPOKE ILL ABOUT RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: NEVER SPOKE ILL
ABOUT RUSSIA.
THAT IS THE EVIDENCE THE
UNITED STATES SENATOR HOLDS UP
TO PROVE THAT THE PRESIDENT MAY
BE WORKING FOR OUR ENEMIES.
SO MAYBE TRUMP DOES LIKE RUSSIA,
WHO KNOWS?
BY THE WAY, HE IS ALLOWED TO IF
HE WANTS TO.
IF THAT DOES NOT MAKE THEM EVIL.
IT MEANS THAT HE DISAGREES WITH
PREVAILING ORTHODOX IN D.C.
THAT IS OKAY.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE SPIRITED
DEBATES OVER QUESTIONS LIKE
THIS.
BUT NO LONGER.
POLICY DIFFERENCES ARE NOW
CRIMINAL OFFENSES.
CNN PROFESSIONAL DUMB PERSON MAX
BOOT LISTED 18 REASONS THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY BE A RUSSIAN SPY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REASONS THEY
ARE POLITICAL REASONS THAT BOOT
DOES NOT AGREE WITH.
FIRING JIM COMING, PULLING OUT
OF SYRIA, CRITICIZING THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
AN SUPPORTING POPULACE.
TO THE WAR CAUCUS IN WASHINGTON
SUCCEEDED IN CRIMINAL DISSENT
FROM THE AGENDA.
IF THIS WAS HAPPENING ANY LESS
TO DEVELOPED COUNTRY, WE WOULD
KNOW WHAT TO CALL IT.
IT IS AN ATTEMPT AT TWO.
A POLITICAL LEADER GETS ELECTED
ON A PLATFORM THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DO NOT
LIKE, SO THEY TRY TO PUT THEM IN
JAIL.
IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME AND
OTHER PLACES, NOW IT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
INSIDE TRUMP ACTIVIST LISA PAGE
DESCRIBED THE FDA'S THINKING IN
HER CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONY BEFORE
CONGRESS.
RUSSIA IS THE MOST DANGEROUS
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, PAGE
REPORTEDLY SAID, BECAUSE RUSSIA
WORKS TO "WEAKEN OUR ABILITY,
AMERICA'S ABILITY, THE WEST
ABILITY TO SPREAD OUR DEMOCRATIC
IDEALS."
SO SPREADING OUR DEMOCRATIC
IDEALS, THAT IS WHAT THE IRAQ
WAR, THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT AMERICA DOES.
THE HIM ONE THING WE MUST TO
FEND AT ALL COSTS PAID WHEN IT
FBI LAWYERS START LIKE A
NEO-PROPAGANDIST?
NO WONDER MAX BOOT IS ON BOARD
WITH US.
THE ENTIRE MEDIA AND POLITICAL
CLASSES ARE WITH MAX BOOT AND
LISA PAGE TOO, THEY HAVE LOST
THEIR MINDS.
THIS PAST SEPTEMBER NBC NEWS
BREATHLESSLY REPORTED THAT
RUSSIA WAS USING "SOPHISTICATED
MICROWAVES TO CAUSE BRAIN DAMAGE
TO U.S. DIPLOMATS IN CUBA."
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING THAT
THOSE DASTARDLY RUSSIANS WOULD
DO JUST BECAUSE, WELL, NOW,
MONTHS LATER SCIENTISTS HAVE
DETERMINED THAT THE KREMLIN
PROBABLY HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT.
THE REAL CULPRIT, NOISE FROM
CRICKETS.
AND NOT EVEN RUSSIAN CRICKETS,
IN THE SHORT TAILED CRICKETS,
NONSLAVIC CRITICS.
WHATEVER.
THE MEDIA DID NOT CORRECT IT,
THEY MOVED ON.
THEY KNOW WHO THE BAD GUYS ARE,
EVIDENCED AS NOT TO DETER THEIR
STORY LINE.
RUSSIAN ESPIONAGE IS SO
WIDESPREAD IN FACT THAT TO THE
ACT OF DENYING THAT YOU SPIED
FOR RUSSIA IS NO CONFIRMATION
THAT YOU DID.
WATCH.
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT'S TWEET
TRYING TO MAKE THE CASE THAT HE
IS NOT A RUSSIAN ASSET REALLY
UNDERCUTS HIS OWN DEFENSE.
THE PRESIDENT'S TWEET COULD NOT
HAVE BEEN SCRIPTED BETTER IF IT
WAS WRITTEN BY HOOTON HIMSELF
PRAYED TO SOMEBODY HAS TO HAVE
TOLD THE PRESIDENT THAT
UNDERCUTTING THE FBI, INSULTING
PAST PRESIDENTS, MEMBERS OF THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT, AND CRITICIZING
THEIR ACTIONS TO KEEP US
SAFE IS ADVANCING RUSSIA'S
MISSION, THE OWN INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE HAS SAID THAT THOSE VR
COMMITTEE HAS SAID THAT THOSE VY
THINGS ARE EXACTLY WHAT RUSSIA
IS AFTER.
SO IN THE PRESIDENT'S RESPONSE,
HE IS REALLY MAKING RUSSIA'S JOB
EASIER.
>> Tucker: YOU SAY THAT YOU
ARE NOT A RUSSIAN AGENT,
THEREFORE YOU ARE A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
WHO PUTS THESE PEOPLE ON TV?
THAT IS A QUESTION WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT.
OVER THE WEEKEND, SPEAKING OF
TELEVISION, JEFF STOKER DECLARED
THAT ANYBODY WHO IS NOT
SPREADING FEAR OF RUSSIA IS
DOING THE BIDDING OF RUSSIA, HE
DID NOT SAY THAT HIMSELF, HE
REALLY SPEAKS IN PUBLIC, INSTEAD
HE SENT HIS MARIONETTE OUT, AS
HE OFTEN DOES TO DELIVER THE
MESSAGE.
>> I WAS WATCHING "GOOD MORNING
AMERICA," AND THEY LEAD WITH
SNOWSTORMS AND SCARES ANIMALS
AND OTHER STORIES, AND NOT THIS,
I JUST KEEP WONDERING IF THE
PUBLIC IS ILL SERVED IF WE DO
NOT MAKE IT REALLY CLEAR WHAT
THE STAKES OF THE STORY ARE, HOW
CAN YOU NOT LEAD WITH THIS
DRAMA?
>> I THINK PLENTY OF TIMES WE
LEAD WITH THIS DRAMA.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
TO THE UNIT HEADS TO THE STEPS
OF THE PALACE READING THE
PROCLAMATION, MESSAGE RECEIVED,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT IS A MEDIAS PROBLEM REALLY
THAT IT DOES NOT TALK ABOUT
RUSSIA ENOUGH?
IT DOES NOT SEEM LIKE THAT IS A
PROBLEM.
>> WHETHER THE PRESIDENT WAS
WORKING FOR RUSSIA.
>> WHETHER DONALD TRUMP WAS
SECRETLY WORKING ON BEHALF OF
RUSSIA.
>> WHETHER TRUMP WAS SECRETLY
WORKING ON BEHALF OF RUSSIA.
>> WHETHER PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
SECRETLY WORKING ON BEHALF OF
RUSSIA.
>> WHETHER THE PRESIDENT WAS
SECRETLY WORKING WITH RUSSIA
AGAINST AMERICA.
>> WHETHER TRUMP WAS SECRETLY
WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE
RUSSIA --
>> WHETHER TRUMP WAS SECRETLY
WORKING ON BEHALF OF RUSSIA.
>> WHETHER PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
WORKING ON RUSSIA'S BEHALF.
>> WHETHER THE SITTING PRESIDENT
WAS SECRETLY WORKING FOR RUSSIA.
>> WHETHER PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
WORKING FOR RUSSIA FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE.
>> Tucker: DOES EVERY SHOW ON
CABLE NEWS HAVE THE SAME WRITER?
WELL, YES, THE DNC.
YOU HAVE HEARD THE SCRIPT SO
MANY TIMES THAT IT IS LIKE
BACKGROUND NOISE.
MUZAK IN AN ELEVATOR, WE DO NOT
PAUSE TO ASK THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION WHICH IS DOES IT
MAKE SENSE?
DOES WHAT THEY ARE SAYING ADD UP
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING
THE BIDDING OF RUSSIA?
IF YOU ARE RUSSIA, LET'S SAY
THAT YOU ARE VLADIMIR PUTIN, HOW
WOULD YOU UNDERMINE AMERICAN
INTEREST?
YOU WILL PROBABLY TRY TO GET
AMERICA STUCK IN COSTLY FOREIGN
WARS.
HE WOULD LOOK AT IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN AND SAY THAT THOSE
WARS HAVE MADE AMERICA MUCH
WEAKER.
WHY NOT TRY TO REPLICATE THAT
EXPERIENCE AND SAY SYRIA AND
LIBYA?
YOU MIGHT ENCOURAGE AMERICA TO
DO THAT.
YOU MIGHT ENCOURAGE THE U.S. TO
ADOPT A SELF-DESTRUCTIVE ENERGY
POLICY.
YOU HAVE THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT
SHARPLY WRITTEN STRICT OIL AND
NATURAL GAS AND THEN WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT, SO THAT THEY PRODUE
LESS ENERGY, WHY WOULD YOU DO
THAT?
BECAUSE GLOBAL ENERGY PRICES
WOULD RISE AND THE U.S. WOULD
HAVE TO IMPORT MORE.
WHO WOULD THAT BENEFIT?
RUSSIA, A PETRO STATE, THEIR
ECONOMY IS GUARANTEED ON ENERGY.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP, WEIRD
BEHAVIOR FOR A SECRET AGENT HAS
ON THE OPPOSITE OF THAT.
TO THE UNITED STATES FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MY LIFETIME IS AN
ENERGY EXPORTER, IN FACT THE
LARGEST PRODUCER OF OIL AND GAS
IN THE WORLD, IS THAT GOOD FOR
RUSSIA?
NO, IT IS NOT.
WHO IS PUSHING THE OPPOSITE?
IT IS A LEFT.
THEY ARE PUSHING A GREEN NEW
DEAL THAT WOULD HAVE THIS
COUNTRY SHUTTING DOWN OIL AND
GAS WELLS ACROSS THE NATION.
HUH?
SOMEDAY WE WILL LOOK BACK IN
SHAME AND CONFUSION AND WONDER
HOW SO MANY SUPPOSEDLY SMART
PEOPLE WENT COMPLETELY OFF THE
DEEP END.
THAT IS THE TASK FOR FUTURE
HISTORIANS.
FOR NOW, IT IS TIME FOR SOME
RADICAL TRANSPARENCY.
LAST FALL THE PRESIDENT ORDERED
THE DECLASSIFICATION AND RELEASE
OF CARTER PAGE'S FISA AS
PUBLICATION.
HOW DID AN AMERICAN CITIZEN WHO
CLEARLY DID NOT ACT AS AN AGENT
FOR RUSSIA HAVE HIS PHONE'S
TAPPED AND HIS EMAIL READ BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
ON WHAT BASIS?
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THAT.
WE STILL DON'T.
SO THE PRESIDENT ORDERED IT.
HE ALSO ORDERED THE UNREDACTED
RELEASE OF ALL TEXT MESSAGES
RELATED TO THEIR RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION SENT BY JIM COMEY,
LISA PAGE, PETER STRZOK, INSTEAD
OF RELEASING THEM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE DITHERED FOR REASONS
THAT WERE NOT CLEAR, THE
PRESIDENT GOT DISTRACTED AND WE
HAVE NEVER SEEN THOSE DOCUMENTS.
IT IS OBVIOUS THAT THE REASON
FOR NOT RELEASING THEM IS NOT
FOR THE SECURITY, THEY LEAK THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE FBI
INVESTIGATION TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ON FRIDAY.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM LEAKING
INFORMATION WHEN IT HELPS THEM.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN RELEASED
BECAUSE OF DOCUMENTS MIGHT
EMBARRASS THE FBI.
THIS AND THE SHADOW
INVESTIGATION HAS CAUSED VASTLY
MORE HARM TO THIS COUNTRY THAN
ANY RUSSIAN FACEBOOK AD.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD ORDER THE
DECLASSIFICATION OF ALL
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO THIS.
IT IS CLEARLY AN ABUSE OF
FEDERAL POWER.
IF YOU WANT TO RESTORE
CONFIDENCE IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, BRING IN SOME
SUNLIGHT.
TELL THE DOJ TO DO THAT.
AND IF DOJ PERSONNEL REFUSES TO
DO THAT, FIRE THEM.
AND REPLACE THEM WITH PEOPLE WHO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY SERVE
ELECTED LEADERS, WHICH IS TO SAY
THE ELECTORATE, WHICH IS TO SAY
VOTERS, THE PEOPLE, AND NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND.
THE PRESIDENT APPEARS TO BE
AFRAID TO DO THIS.
HE APPEARS TO BE INTIMIDATED BY
HIS OWN EMPLOYERS, BUT WHY?
WHAT CAN OFFICIAL WASHINGTON DOD